mr beast recently did an interview with
colin and samir who are two youtubers
who have a pretty good show uh where
they interview different uh content
creators um and he
elaborated on uh a known fact now that
his monthly content creation expenditure
currently sits at four million dollars
mr b spends four million dollars a month
to make content it's 48 million dollars
annually he has
69.3 million subscribers on his main
youtube channel nice he reportedly
spends 48 million a year in content
creation he had 700 million views in the
last 28 days alone almost a billion
views per month and that is the combined
population of the united states brazil
russia and japan simply the internet
loves mr beast he's got a 70
audience retention rate in each upload
which is bonkers and he probably is the
pioneer he's by far the highest paid
youtuber and he has absolutely
led a revolution on the video platform
we've got two quotes from him here where
he says first i woke up i studied
youtube i studied videos i studied
filmmaking i went to bed and that was my
life anyone who thinks that mr bees got
lucky or sorta kind of stumbled into
this has lost their minds this guy
uploaded videos for about five years or
so before he really broke it open and he
studied it he became an expert at how to
do everything from thumbnails to titles
to the structure of the video how to
tell stories how to hold the audience's
attention and he now is reaping the
benefits of years and years of hard work
it's an incredible story he also said i
only want money so i can make better
videos so i can grow my channel i don't
care about making money i don't care
about time i just want to make the best
videos on the planet
when i first heard that this was his
perspective you kind of are like i don't
know it's easy to say when you're making
millions of dollars and you're spending
millions of dollars a month on videos
but i've talked to him before and i'm
blown away he has an opportunity not
only to change people's lives where he
gives away cars and money and houses and
do all these positive things but he also
genuinely believes that his entire
purpose is to make the best videos on
the internet which he's clearly doing
and then two is to help people and i
think it's pretty incredible that we
have somebody who frankly is one of the
largest philanthropists under the age of
you know 30 35 years old in the world
but everyone knows him simply as a
youtuber he's given away millions and
millions of dollars on an annual basis
and he continues to help as many people
as he possibly can it's pretty
incredible but the idea of spending four
million dollars a month on videos is not
exactly what most people think when they
think of oh that guy's just a youtuber
you can see here that the videos he has
uh on his channel are all very different
everything from an extreme
challenge game of tag to the last to
leave the circle wins money he got
hunted by the fbi probably not uh you
can carry a million dollars if you can
keep if you if you can carry a million
dollars you can keep it and then
everything like i bought everything in
five stores i've watched one video where
he just walks into the store and he
walks up to a random person like best
buy he goes hey uh in the next 30
seconds whatever you can grab will buy
for you and people what and they like
freak out they start running around the
store trying to grab stuff and then
another time he went to a jewelry store
which like it's one thing to do at like
the grocery store whatever you can grab
in 30 seconds right or in five minutes
or whatever
a jewelry store you could rack up a big
bill real fast yeah and he said to
somebody he said whatever you can get in
you know the next five minutes or
whatever uh i'll buy for you and they
rack and like the bill was you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars or
whatever jeez so it's pretty cool again
i saw he was giving away houses for a
dollar or something like that like he he
had you know five or six or seven houses
and in the video he they're like you
know how much money did you make on that
video he's like we spent all in probably
1.3 million dollars on one video
literally they went around and they
bought four or five houses uh six houses
and they gave them away for a dollar
each and then they had the production
everything they had to pay employees and
all this kind of stuff so he said they
spent 1.3 million dollars he said he
made less than half of he said he made
less than 500k
on the actual video on youtube uh and
then there was a brand deal involved but
he was like we didn't get anywhere close
to 1.3 so he's like some of these videos
i make more on some i make less but at
the end of the day i'm spending a lot of
money to make these videos and what was
the numbers 48 million dollars a year
he's spending to make youtube videos
it's crazy and they're not all
profitable like like this is not just oh
i made 2 million and i spent a million
of it uh sometimes he actually loses
money on videos but it's all in an
effort to get more people to subscribe
to the channel notice he only he only
puts out like one or two what are you
two looking at i'm smiling because i
literally just use an example of how not
every video is profitable and then he
said
not every video he does is probably it's
cool to see that he puts out like one to
two a month though he i
mr beast he broke the internet he broke
the internet broke it he broke the
internet he he broke the algorithm of
the internet he understands it better
than anyone else um and he puts out like
one to two a month right so he spent so
much time making these videos and
perfecting the videos the ideas the the
actual content creation itself and then
the production like afterwards it's
insane uh shout out he is from north
carolina so i want to shout that out
facts facts and yeah look his story's
just incredible the fact that he good
guy noted good guy the first video he
put up that like really really went
viral after testing it all was this this
dude counted to a hundred thousand
he put a video on it it took like 40
hours he counted to a hundred thousand
city counted
some big number he counted to it he's
also a million that's insane he also i
think read maybe the dictionary before
or something like
like i mean in the beginning like
obviously he was just doing all kinds of
crazy stuff what people would watch and
so it ended up working
now though our friend ian borthwick over
at seatgeek by the way
i never ever ever ever give free
advertising to anyone
but see geek is back i will say that see
geek is back go check twitter see geek
is back they've got sports back so
they've been advertising on all these
podcasts and shows and all this stuff go
make ian's uh life easier go download
seekgeek uh but ian said the super bowl
got 96 million views mr beast averages
98 million views per week
one creator versus the most dominant
property on television
that is a bonker stat yeah that's wild i
mean look at his most popular uploads
142 million 138 million 128 million
those are insane numbers he basically
runs the super bowl every like couple of
months 142 million that's close to half
the country
right it's 330 million people
yeah i mean if we go back go back to the
super bowl data again like if you think
about how big that is the super bowl has
all of this energy and effort leading up
to it uh and he just puts out a video on
youtube and gets the same amount of
views is absolutely nuts what are you
guys laughing john found the video in
2017 he counted to a hundred thousand
and the first thing in the video says
this video was originally 40 hours long
he he put up a youtube video that's 24
hours but he said adobe caps at 24 hours
so some parts are sped up to get it
under 24 hours the youtube video is
literally 23 hours and 50 minutes
and it has in the head and it's just him
counting it has almost 200 or 24 million
views on
he's the goat youtube has 2.29
billion users and 142 million of them
wants to
watch the video that's crazy right
almost 10 of youtube ended up watching a
video with mr beast it's it's just it is
frankly it's not only uh impressive i
think that it is just uh a huge kudos to
him for being able to do it and then
also everyone thinks about the video
content that's what you see but the fact
that he hired so many people that he was
willing to spend the money to make the
videos to actually build the channels
and now he's not just got the mitsubishi
and he's got a bunch of channels that he
understands reinvesting in the platform
has been wildly valuable to them right
and that ultimately ends up driving what
is you know the yeah but i think
i think the other thing too is like
people when they see youtubers uh and
not specifically him but just in general
i think the the thought process is
generally these guys make dumb videos on
the internet they go viral and this is
what kids like and they get a bunch of
views but mr beast uh if you look more
into kind of his background and his
philosophy behind the videos he's very
calculated he has like a certain i'll
call it even like an equation basically
of how he how he formulates and makes
every video how he comes up with
different ideas how he uh orchestrates
the video how it's produced who he's
involved with the amount of money he's
giving away all this kind of stuff right
it's down to the detail uh everything is
thought out beforehand there's no kind
of uh luck i would say behind it right
like there's certainly uh some virality
aspect of it that you can't always
control but he's very clear about like
hey i know certain things are gonna go
really really well i know how to make a
video go viral and now for me it's just
about doing the best videos the biggest
videos and doing as many as i can so
when it comes to someone like that uh he
he's almost like an artist you know what
i mean like he knows exactly what he's
doing he's built up a loyal following
his videos are really really really good
he spends a lot of money on doing them
uh and yet to your point he has just
reinvested now and when you have the
ability to spend a million dollars two
million dollars three million dollars
per video he's spending 4 million per
month 48 million per year on videos
that's a massive production budget and
it gives him the ability to do wild
things like give out millions of dollars
of cash give out free homes and all the
stuff that attracts all the viewers give
him credit he kept his friends close
from so his childhood friends guys he's
grew up with that kind of helped him
understand all this stuff um he stayed
humble and he's a huge philanthropist i
mean he gives away literally like he
said millions and millions of dollars
every single year to help other
individuals
guys the guy's a beast in my eyes
literally
that was good mr b's noted good guy
good guy philanthropist
and on top of it
probably one of the most entertaining
creators in the world like he does more
views
than movies do
and it's incredible to think about how
much effort goes into a movie and
creating this highly cinematic
experience and all stuff and this guy
literally has a couple of cameras and he
goes and locks himself into jail for 24
hours in i mean he has production
budgets that are the same as some of
these movies he does have production
budget right but still the fact that he
can i saw one where he created an igloo
an icy glue
in a uh a skating ring and he just sat
in there and he said i'm locked in here
for 24 hours he was freezing his ass off
and i was like this guy is wild and so i
asked him i was like what was up with
that one and he was just like yeah that
was cold
right so it's like he just
uh was in there in an all ice like uh
glass house and just chilled in there
for 24 hours what's up guys bang bang
your boy pomp thanks so much for
watching the best business show our goal
is to make this the largest most
actionable business show in the world
and to do that we need your help we've
partnered with sofi as our exclusive
sponsor because they have a piece of
software that we think will help you
take the information that we share on a
daily basis and make it actionable we
want every single person to pursue and
achieve financial security and financial
freedom in order to do that you gotta
act and sofi allows you to do it so you
can go to sofi.com pomp today you can
open up an account and when you open up
an account you can invest in all sorts
of different types of assets etfs
individual stocks ipos bitcoin
cryptocurrencies they even have an
automated investing function if you want
to invest sofi can help you they've got
a couple of different offers that you
can benefit from the first open an
invest account and they'll give you up
to a thousand bucks for free kind of a
no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right so far doesn't care
where your current account is but if you
transfer it from that place to sofi
they'll pay you up to five thousand
dollars for doing it why wouldn't you do
it it's up to five thousand dollars for
free head on over to sofi.com today to
get started and come back tomorrow and
watch more of the best business show
together we're gonna build the biggest
show in the world
[Music]